Aynsley give me a better idea why don't
you just make the same video you did a
few years ago I'm sure people are too
dumb to realize you already made this
diode this way you can make videos
forever you can become unstoppable this
is a demo hey guys today we're gonna I'm
gonna Google myself
I've never done this before I'm pretty
excited have you guys ever googled
yourself
that's cute you're not famous well if
you happen to be a youtuber or any
summer former public person googling
yourself is kind of like masturbating
but with razor blades blue to your hand
you know you think it's gonna be nice
but really it's just gonna be a bunch of
[ __ ] it's not a good metaphor yeah
that's a good metaphor for today I am
going to Google myself I've never done
this before so you know it should be
pretty interesting also I'm doing a poll
if you can ask me what what your
favorite day of the month is let's go
PewDiePie is a child
[Music]
oh that's why I pity pie is a child
rapist great right that's what shows up
this is what shows up can you imagine
like someone's parents who have no idea
what the [ __ ] I am and then like who is
PewDiePie PewDiePie is Oh a child rapist
[Music]
there was this news about three-pack
dying I'm not sure if it's true or not
three-pack died when he was taken off
life support after he stopped breathing
during water polo practice is that true
is that true I don't I mean it's really
sad if it's true it would have been on
some kind of top five death list you
know like top five saddest anime deaths
or top five saddest moments of 2016 you
know what the I don't I'm really
confused by the whole thing cuz the top
five videos are not covering it PT pi is
dead of course
ohuh with proof alright that's
interesting yeah that pretty much
settles the deal
[Music]
hey hey Petey pie is the kazoo kid you
know what the [ __ ] is this the dumbest
youtuber no how dare you I have an IQ
over at least a couple Oh because of
this [ __ ] video thanks orsha
appreciate you jesus [ __ ] christ
pewdiepie is the best youtuber well
you've heard of here first folks thanks
everybody
appreciate ya 10 reasons why pewdiepie
is the most subscribed youtube channel
because of this amazing fan art PTP age
27 you won that round
Google goddamnit 27 I'm getting too old
for this can someone like younger and
more attractive and actually funny too
please take over because I'm getting a
lot I'm getting tired Ryan from talking
kids toy reviews please come on you need
to you need to grow up faster I assume
you're not gonna be you know cute and
adorable anymore and you're gonna look
like this and you're gonna have to
you're gonna have to take over Ellen for
me alright
I mean come on they're they they're the
biggest YouTube channel clearly if
anything they've they've already taken
over I mean ask anyone Hey oh that's
Ryan store review that's that's it who's
the biggest youtuber this is this is
really weird to me because clearly it
should be saying Ryan's toy review I
don't understand why it came up like a
like a this is the answer result because
I'm gonna have to report this and feed
some feedback this the biggest youtuber
is ryan toy reviews reviews LOL
everybody knows that everyone everyone
knows that his net worth 4 million
that's cute 2017 worth right now okay
what is this all right all right all
right what do we got what's the verdict
61 Oh coming okay see I don't have that
much money
I wish though that would be great
honestly that would be great that would
be nice
how did they come up with these numbers
I'm really curious is that how much I
should be making am i am i doing
something wrong here
oh you guys not clicking on the ads like
who what's happening all right and we
need are we gonna have to have a talk do
I need do I need to put more [ __ ] mid
rolls what the [ __ ] because he's Swedish
and in a 56 percent tax bracket thanks
for bringing that up
Thanks I actually have a limited company
so it's it's 21% taxes what do you think
I'm not driving a [ __ ] Lambo you
think I'm gonna pay 56 percent taxes
people think oh he's so humble and
modest no no no no no I just don't want
to pay 56 percent taxes could be even
more [ __ ] you gotta be [ __ ] stupid
I'll drive a [ __ ] Nissan any day I'll
think about 21 percent thank you very
much PewDiePie Isis oh yeah I forgot
about this this is actually news this is
actually news they posted this picture a
news article posted this picture oh yeah
that was the that was the news I was
suspended from Twitter I got suspended
because they thought I was being hacked
because I was acting like a [ __ ]
[ __ ] PewDiePie is hot
what the [ __ ] is this my name is BG
kumbi and I'm making this video because
I am sick and tired of no negative
comments from the bro army on my
PewDiePie video you deserve all those
negative
comments you're all buying a looking
[ __ ] do people realize that what you're
doing is considered cybernetic bullying
if you're so scared of cybernetic
bullying why don't you just close your
eyes why don't you just look wait I just
want to say the the bro army is a full
of a bunch of children what the [ __ ]
does this guy think he is I'm more
muscular than PewDiePie PewDiePie is
lightweight what the [ __ ] you'll see
this yeah this is what happens when you
dedicate yourself to training all day
every day so what happens when your
nipples are too far apart
Oh instead of sitting in your room
yelling and screaming and video games
like a selfish little spoiled child oh
really
Oh what PewDiePie does oh do you think
that's what I do
I bet PewDiePie's watching this video
right now and that's being a little
jealous no I am not jealous of this man
it's twice the blood do you look very
nice though because he knows I'm more of
a real man than him that's not true do
not listen to this man
I got bigger muscles oh really oh really
I challenge you BG kumbi for a money
all right look at this vegetarian body
I bet he doesn't even lift bro I left I
left your mom's ass I love this one top
ten secret youtuber talents pity pie
what the [ __ ] is my secret YouTube
talent what the [ __ ] is it because I
don't have a secret I don't have a
secret talent I can't wiggle my ears
yeah I can
can you yeah let's see if I can you yeah
I want to be able to do sorry I could be
excited and witty in your ears only able
to do that yeah oh
so alpha doesn't have any talent huh
PewDiePie is actually surprisingly good
at beatboxing literally I had no idea
how to make an intro so I just made some
[ __ ] noises with my mouth that's not
a secret talent I have my tongue I have
a long tongue
alright it freaks people out phone
number really
what is the meaning of PT pi such a
question that I always get and the
answer is always so [ __ ] ask anyone what
their [ __ ] user I name means it's
just like it sounded good I guess that's
why I picked it thanks for watching this
video
why did I do that if you enjoyed it
check out another one I think you'll
enjoy more videos
don't you like videos watch this one
it's the same video it's this one watch
it again